Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
Throughout this series, we have seen many
impressive applications of artificial intelligence.
These techniques are capable of learning the
piano from the masters of the past, beat formidable
teams in complex games like DOTA 2, perform
well in the game Sonic, The Hedgehog, or help
us revive and impersonate famous actors who
are not with us anymore.
However, what is often not spoken about is
how narrow, or how general these AI programs
are.
A narrow AI means an agent that can perform
one task really well, but cannot perform other,
potentially easier tasks.
The holy grail of machine learning research
is a general AI that is capable of obtaining
new knowledge by itself through abstract reasoning.
This is similar to how humans learn and is
a critical step in obtaining a general AI.
And to tackle this problem, scientists at
DeepMind created a program that is able to
generate a large amount of problems that test
abstract reasoning capabilities.
They are inspired by human IQ-tests with all
the these questions about sizes, colors and
progressions.
They designed the training process in a way
that the algorithm is given training data
on the progression of colors, but it is never
shown similar progression examples that involve
object sizes.
The concept is the same, but the visual expression
of the progression is different.
A human easily understands the difference,
but teaching abstract reasoning like this
to a computer sounds almost impossible.
However, now we have a tool that can create
many of these questions and the correct answers
to them.
And I will note that some of these are not
as easy as many people would expect.
For instance, a vertical number progression
is relatively easy to spot, but have a good
look at these ones...not so immediately apparent,
right?
Going back to being able to generate lots
and lots of data...the black-belt Fellow Scholars
know exactly what this means.
This means that we can train a neural network
to perform this task!
Unfortunately, existing techniques and architectures
perform quite poorly.
Despite the fact that we have a ton of training
data, they could only get 22-42% of the answers
right.
However, these networks are amazing at doing
other things, like writing novels or image
classification, therefore this means that
their generalization capabilities are not
too great when we go outside their core domain.
This new technique goes by the name "Wild
Relation Network" and is trained in a way
that encourages reasoning.
It is also designed in a way that it not only
outputs a guess for the results, but also
tries to provide a reason for it, which interestingly,
further improved the accuracy of the network.
And what is this accuracy we are talking about?
It finds the correct solution 62.6% of the
time.
But it gets better, because this result was
measured in the presence of distractor objects
like these annoying lines and circles.
This is quite confusing, even for humans,
so a result above 60% is quite remarkable.
And it gets even better, because if we don't
use these distractions, it is correct 78%
of the time.
Wow!
This is indeed a step towards teaching an
AI how to reason, and as the authors made
this dataset publicly available for everyone,
I expect a reasonable amount of research works
appearing in this area in the near future
- who knows, perhaps even in the next few
months.
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!